من جديد وللمرة الثانية صواريخ
موسكو تخترق ستار الناتو وتنتهك
اجواءه في رسالة مرعبة وماكرون
يسحب وسام الشرف من الرئيس
الروسي بوتين وجورجيا ميلوني
ترد. الروس يباغتون الاتحاد
الاوروبي ويغلقون شريان الطاقة.
واشنطن تقترح الارض مقابل السلام
بايقاف الحرب الاوكرانية. فهل
يتحقق ذلك? المنطاد الصيني يكشف
وجسم اخر يحلق في اجواء الولايات
المتحدة وواشنطن ترد على الصين
برسالة نووية. زلزال تركيا
وسوريا يواصل حصد الارواح. وبين
الامل واليأس شعرة بل تنقطع خلال
الساعات والايام القادمة. زوجة
زعيم كوريا الشمالية تتزين
بصاروخ عابر للقارات. فكيف ذلك
والفلسطينيون يوجهون صفعة
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي. وبعد تنبؤه
بزلزال تركيا المدمر العالم
الهولندي يتوقع زلزالا اخر في
ثلاث دول عربية. موسكو تتحرش
بحلف الناتو. بعض الرسائل لا تصل
بالكلام ولا يكفي التهديد
والتحذير ليرسل الروس رسائل اخرى
للناتو وعلى الطريقة السوفيتية
الخاصة. وهنا مجددا وللمرة
يعلنها القائد العام للقوات
المسلحة الاوكرانية فاليريز
لوجني ان صاروخين روسيين من طراز
كاليبر دخلا المجال الجوي
لموددوفا ثم عبرا المجال الجوي
الروماني قبل دخول اوكرانيا وفقا
لوكالة رويترز والصواريخ الروسية
اذا تتبختر في سماع اعضاء الناتو
وبوتين يوصل رسالته للحلف بعبور
تلك الصواريخ ثم عودتها نحو
اوكرانيا اليكم انه لا يمكن تحت
اي ظرف ان يتم تسليمها في
الاسابيع القليلة المقبلة. اضاف
الجيش الاوكراني ان عدة صواريخ
روسية اخترقت اجواء رومانيا
ومولدوفا. ليس ذلك فقط بل ان
روسيا شنت هجوما واسعا بوابل من
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيرة
المتفجرة التي استهدفت عددا من
مواقع الطاقة في اوكرانيا بعد
جولة فولوديمرزيلانسكي في اوروبا
وامريكا للمطالبة بمزيد من اسلحة
في رسالة روسية اخرى وهذه المرة
للاتحاد الاوروبي. مولدوفا ردت
على صواريخ موسكو على استحياء.
حيث استدعت السفير الروسي لديها
على خلفية اختراق مجالها الجوي
حسب فرانس بريس لتأخذ ايطاليا
دور المنتقد للاوروبيين بدلا عن
روسيا. حيث انتقدت رئيسة الوزراء
الايطالية جورجيا ميلوني
الاجتماع الفرنسي الالماني مع
زيلانسكي دعوة غير مناسبة بحسب
موقع الالماني لتعود وتوجه
انتقادها مباشرة نحو الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون بسبب
مأدبة العشاء التي استضاف فيها
نظيره الاوكراني زينونسكي واصفة
لاجتماع الرئيسين في باريس بانه
خطأ سياسي. لكن ماكرون لا يلتفت
لتحذيرات ميلوني ويعلن منح نظيره
الاوكراني جوقة الشرف الرئيس
الفرنسي لا يكتفي بذلك. ويقول
انه ينتظر الوقت المناسب لسحب
وسام الشرف الفرنسي من نظيره
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فكيف سيرد
بوتين. ومن توترات الحرب الى
طاولة السلام حيث كانت صحيفة
السويسرية قالت وقد نشرناه لهم
في فيديو مسبقا قالت ان رئيس
وكالة المخابرات المركزية
الامريكية عرض في منتصف يناير من
عام على كييف وموسكو خطة للتسوية
شمال تخلي اوكرانيا عن عشرين
بالمائة من اراضيها لصالح روسيا
مقابل السلام. ليرد اليوم مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل بودليق
بقوله ان كييب لم تتلقى اي مقترح
للسلام بمبدأ الارض مقابل
السلام. وان بلاده لن تتنازل عن
اراضيها التي سيطرت عليها روسيا.
اما روسيا فردت على لسان المتحدث
باسم الكرملين الذي اعتبر
التقارير مجرد خدعة حسب وصفه.
بينما قالت الخارجية الروسية ان
موسكو مستعدة للتفاوض مع كييف
ولكن دون شروط مسبقة وبناء على
الوقائع الجديدة القائمة على
الارض. يقولها الروس باختصار. ما
وضعنا ايدينا عليه اصبح ملكا
لنا. يا نهار اسود ومنيل. لينطلق
الروس نحو حرب اخرى لكن مع
القارة هذه المرة وردا على تحديد
الغرب سقفا لاسعار النفط الروسي.
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
الكسندر نوفاك ان موسكو تعتزم
خفض انتاجها النفطي طواعية
بمقدار خمسمائة الف برميل يوميا
في مارس المقبل فيما اكد الرئيس
الصربي الكسندر فوتشيتش ان بلاده
قد تضطر لفرض عقوبات على روسيا
بسبب الضغوط الغربية عليها. بكين
تضرب وواشنطن ترد. الاستخبارات
تعمل على قدم وساق. الاقمار
الصناعية ترصد والرادارات لا
تتوقف. وهذا هو حال الامريكان في
الوقت الحالي. يراقبون كل حركة
وسكنة للصين وادواتها. وبعد ازمة
من طاري الصيني. ها هو البيت
الابيض يعلن ان واشنطن اسقطت
جسما طائرا بحجم سيارة صغيرة حلق
على علو مرتفع فوق الاسكا بناء
على الرئيس جو بايدن لتعيش
الولايات المتحدة قلقا غير مسبوق
لا يعلمون من اين يتجسس عليهم
اصحاب العيون الضيق. هنا تحركت
واشنطن للرد على بكين لتكشف
القوات الامريكية عن اطلاق صاروخ
باليستي عابر للقارات فيما وصف
بانه استعراض للردع النووي اظهر
دقة وموثوقية نظام الصواريخ
الامريكية الباليستية العابرة في
رسالة واضحة للصين بعد قضية
المنطاد الصيني. وبالعودة لازمة
المنطاد هنا مسؤول كبير في
الخارجية الامريكية يؤكد ان
جمهورية الصين الشعبية قد ارسلت
مناطيد او بالونات المراقبة فوق
اكثر من اربعين دولة في خمس
قارات. مشيرا الى ان ادارة بايدن
تتواصل مع البلدان مباشرة حول
نطاق هذا البرنامج والاجابة على
اي بحسب موقع الحرة. بصيص امل
يختفي تحت الانقاض. الرعب لم
ينتهي. القلق يستمر. القهر يملأ
القلوب. والقلوب قد بلغت الحناجر
صمت مطبق وتعابير الالم والحزن
هي من تتحدث. وبين ركام كل هذه
المشاعر وبين حطام الزلزال يكمن
بصيص امل قد ينقطع مع مضي
الساعات. وبعد من مائة وعشرين
ساعة ينقطع الامل رويدا رويدا
ويزداد اليأس بوجود ناجين تحت
الانقاض لكن هنا يخرج هذا الرجل
وهو يتلو القرآن الكريم. بعد ان
امضى اكثر من مائة واربع ساعات
تحت الانقاض فيالقلبه الخاشع.
وهنا صلاة الفجر تنقذ اللاعب
الكاميروني كيفن سوني لعب نادهتي
سبور من الزلزال. ليقول سوني
بقاؤه على قيد الحياة جاء بسبب
انتظاره لصلاة الفجر ذلك اليوم.
لننتقل الى مشهد مؤثر لاب تركي
يبحث عن اولاده تحت الانقاض بعد
زلزال تركيا. ووسط يأس وبكاء
الاب تتعالى صيحاته تجاه الركام
لعله يجد بصيص امل بنجاتهم.
فياله من موقف يقطر القلب دما
امامه. في سوريا قال مدير المدني
انه تم الانتهاء من عمليات البحث
والانقاذ وحانت مرحلة البحث
وانتشال الجثث. مضيفا انه لم
يدخل اي فريق انقاذ دولي الى
شمال غربي سوريا وان الامم
المتحدة لم تقدم شيء. الاحداث
والتطورات. زوجة الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي تظهر وهي ترتدي قلادة
على شكل اكبر صاروخ باليستي عابر
بالقارات في البلاد. السيدة ريسو
جو ظهرت مبتسمة والقلادة تحيط
بعنقها على مأدبة طعام برفقة
زوجها كيم جونغ اون وابنتها ولية
العهد المتوقعة كيم جو اي وحولهم
قادة عسكريون وفق صحيفة تلجراف
البريطانية. الهجمات الفردية
الفلسطينية ترعب الكيان
الاسرائيلي. ليتعدى الرد
الاسرائيلي منفذي العمليات الى
ذويهم بيوتهم ومساكنهم. وبعد
عملية الداس التي نفذها شاب
فلسطيني ليحصد قتيلين واربعة
مصابين اسرائيليين في محطة
حافلات بالقدس. وزير الامن
القومي للكيان اتمار بن غفير
يأمر شرطة الاحتلال باعداد خطة
لتنفيذ عملية السور الواقي
اثنين. بينما انطلقت ضربات جوية
متبادلة بين اسرائيل والمقاومة
الفلسطينية في قطاع غزة. والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن اعتراض القبة
الحديدية لصاروخ اطلق من القطاع.
بعد تنبؤه بزلزال تركيا المدمر
العالم الهولندي فرانك هوجربيتس
يتوقع زلزالا في مصر والعراق
ولبنان. اوروبا تراقب صواريخ
بوتين بقلق والولايات المتحدة لا
تغمض اعينها امام ادوات الصين
التجسسية والعالم يصوب نظره نحو
ضحايا الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
مجهول لهذه المعمورة.